hi Samuel leaves here and on this video
I'm gonna do something crazy I might
regret doing this and this is something
that I don't ever see any other property
gurus trainers or any youtubers doing
and that is I'm going to reveal I'm
going to expose to you exactly what my
2019 property investment business plan
is I'm going to tell you what I'm
planning to buy over the next 12 months
in property myself personally people
told me that I shouldn't do this I
shouldn't put it out there they've said
other people will try and copy you other
people will try and steal your ideas
keep it close keep your cards close to
your chest although I understand that I
think that when you speak something out
rather than being fearful that other
people are going to copy you or that
it's not gonna happen you'll fail and
then you look stupid oh I'd rather think
that when I speak it out I'm speaking it
into existence people will then cheer me
on and then if people want to copy me
and join the club that's fine that's why
I've run this youtube channel to help
people become successful in property so
I'm gonna reveal exactly what I'm gonna
buy over the next twelve months so
that's what I'm gonna be doing on this
video right now please do show me some
love by smashing that like button below
also subscribe to the channel if you're
not already subscribed and don't forget
as well to turn the notification bow on
so that you never miss one of these
videos again so what am I gonna be
buying over the next 12 months well last
year I bought 26 properties I only
anticipated to buy 10 so I did I was way
above target and if you want to watch
that video and exactly what happened you
can do that up on the link I usually on
average will buy one property per month
so over a year typically are I'll aim to
buy 12 properties so over the next 12
months
I'm planning on buying nine houses it
might be a lot more than that but
knowing properties is what I've budget
for and that is just myself personally I
do have an investment company
we're on business partners with my
brother that company's doing some really
great things we're planning on buying
some commercial properties doing some
developments we're also looking for our
own new office building for all our
staff so that's going on the business
side but this video is really more about
me personally and hopefully you'll be
able to relate to that because it's not
massive big fancy stuff and I'm assuming
that the fact that you're watching this
video you're either just starting or
quite early on
looking to build your residential
portfolio which is what I'm still doing
at the moment so of the nine properties
they're going to be split into three
sections some 1 by 3 3 and 3 and the
first group of 3 is going to be serviced
apartments service departments are
really great for two reasons and let me
explain why let me tell you why I'm so
excited about buying service departments
number one I live in the Midlands and
they've really bottomed out price-wise
I bought some apartments in Walsall I'm
them right in the center on Bridge
Street of Warsaw I paid eighty five
thousand pounds for these apartments ten
years ago in Warsaw
currently today they're worth around
about seventy five thousand pounds so
over the last ten years they've actually
dropped in value we know that on average
properties double every 10 years these
have actually not just stayed the same
they've dropped in value over the last
ten years now after every session will
always come an expansion and after an
expansion will always come a recession
more salt as an area has not been in a
big recession in fact I've got houses in
Warsaw I've gone up a lot but apartment
seems to be really low at the moment
they seem to be almost out of fashion I
think the series friends came in and
suddenly a corn what an apartment
because they're watching friends in
apartments and apartments went really
inflated but I feel like they've really
bottomed out right now and I think that
the fact that they've bottomed out I
have a feeling that apartments are going
to be come back in fashion over time and
either feeling that the prices are going
to go back up because at the moment
they're right to the bottom Apartments
I think I got really good things you
need to be careful when you're buying
apartments is the ground rent and the
service charge you need to make sure
that you calculate that and they were
showing investment service departments
wire wire service accommodation so good
well serviced accommodation is when you
rent out a property or a room or
whatever it might be and you rent it out
instead of putting a ten in there you
have a guest in there so it's like a
hotel without having staff it's all
automated it's all systemized
rather than buying an apartment for a
good price and then just renting it out
for say five six seven hundred pound a
month I'm going to be buying a property
at an apartment and I'm going to be
renting out my plan a is gonna be
renting it out as a serviced
accommodation so what's gonna happen is
I'm gonna get guests coming in there
which literally can double triple or
even quadruple your return on invest
new monthly cash flow so on that basis
what are the figures going up like I'm
wearing my planning on buying well
service departments work best in big
city centers really buzzing city centers
so I'm gonna be buying but my closest
big buzzing Center city center is
Litchfield but this feels very expensive
and you know you're talking probably at
least 150,000 pounds just for a studio
apartment which is the returns aren't
going to be as good if I went a little
bit further afield Birmingham is the
next biggest buzzing city Birmingham is
from about half an hour from where I
live
Birmingham you can buy apartments for as
little as one hundred thousand pounds
yeah it's a really buzzing popular city
so all I'm gonna be buying service
departments in Birmingham and I'm gonna
buy a minimum of three over the next
twelve months my advice to you would be
if you're looking to buy service
departments for around about 100 to 150
thousand pounds I would say fines the
biggest buzzing most buzzing city near
where you live and buy there now in
other videos I've said that don't worry
about having to buy close to where you
live so why am I suggesting that you buy
close to where you deliver to service
departments well a couple of reasons
firstly is if you have to travel far
even just for the viewings in the first
place and the setting up process if
you're driving six hours each weighs 12
hour round trip you've got to put a
value on your time so I would say for
spying service departments if you can if
you live in such an expensive area the
returns are going to be so like there
maybe do look further afield but I think
if you can buy close to home that's not
bad I think secondly is I know
Birmingham really well because I live
close if I was to buy in Liverpool I
might be able to buy an apartment a bit
cheaper but I don't know the area I
might have to spend a lot of time
investigate in the area
I'm also gonna have to then drive to
view it so the amount of money I'm going
to lose because I'm spending my time is
probably not worth it so service
departments in Birmingham I'm gonna buy
three I'm going to be spending between
100 and 150 thousand pound per
apartments and I would like to be making
at least a minimum of five hundred pound
profit per month of the apartment I
think that's very conservative also as a
plan B if serviced accommodation becomes
very regulated and I'm not able to do
that anymore become saturated is even if
I went it out as a single let apartment
the economist I'm going behind the
return will still be pretty decent
that's gonna be three of my houses
service departments and looking in
Birmingham next HMOs what are haters
will hate to a house of multiple
occupancy when you buy a house and you
split it up and you rent it out on a
room-by-room basis
the reason HMOs are really good is
because instead of getting rent from
just one person you getting rent from
multiple people which means that cash
flows better now HMOs have become pretty
regulated over the last few years
sometimes you need licenses sometimes
you need planning permission so they're
just about as regulated as I think
they're ever gonna get or while that's
can be a little bit annoying because of
the red tape it's also really good
because I understand the HMO industry
very well people are a bit scared off
because of the rules and regulations but
I can't imagine them getting any more
regulated so I think HMOs are very safe
I think that you know where you stand if
you buy a hey Chando and you bought in
the right area again where am I going to
be looking for HMOs I'm gonna be looking
in the Midlands again because I've got a
really good team a really good network
in the Midlands prices in the Midlands
have not gone up super high like London
but they are going up so I think the
capital appreciation is gonna be good I
know the area while I understand it HMOs
work in many different parts of the
country but I'm personally gonna be
looking in the Midlands finally looking
at Burnley don't war sort and
surrounding areas kind of figures on I
think you'd be talking is I said in my
book by low rent hard that you were
talking twenty five thousand pounds per
letter ballroom that was a couple of
years ago prices have now gone up but
also rents have gone up so now I'm
looking to spend a maximum of thirty
five thousand pounds per letter ballroom
which means if it's a four-bed hey Chen
mo are bike for one hundred and forty
thousand pound max and then I should be
able to rent out for a minimum of four
hundred pounds per room so a for better
HMO you buy it for one forty and you're
gonna rent it out for sixteen hundred
pounds a month of course you're going to
have costs involved but again your cash
flow each month should be very high
giving me a return on investment at at
least twenty percent so on about 3h
ammos in the Midlands three service
departments in Birmingham so far I'll
tally up to six pockets so what are the
next three properties that I'm gonna buy
I get by the way don't forget if you
enjoyed this video please do smash that
like and don't forget to subscribe if
you haven't
already done that thank you so much the
last three properties as part of the
nine houses over the year are going to
be straightforward below market value by
select properties
when I say single at buy-to-let it just
means a house that you rent out to a
family nothing complicated
you're not splitting up gluten again if
you clever you're not doing as a guest
house just to straightforward buy select
what am I going to be doing that well
because I think that when I first
started in property by tonight that was
the actual bread and butter and looking
at my portfolio now if I look across the
board I love my bite set properties it
actually made me a lot of money in
capital appreciation and gone up in
value I've had the same tenants in there
for five six seven years very very
little work my thinking is while people
are scared that's when you should be
greedy as Warren Buffett says at the
moment with the tax changes and we've
all the things that are going on in the
country with the uncertainty and brexit
there's a lot of people that are quite
fearful there's a lot of people that are
quite scared at the moment so it's a
really good opportunity to buy
properties below market value because
people are thinking oh I just want to
get rid of my property you're always
gonna have it all and then they're
wanting to sell so I think right now is
a really good opportunity to buy
properties find motivated sellers
negotiate a good below market value and
if you think about it if you find a
house that's valued at 100,000 pound and
you buy it for eighty five thousand
pound that negotiation might have only
taken you a couple of hours but you've
made effectively fifteen thousand pounds
in a couple of hours from finding it
negotiating in a couple of hours I don't
know about you but fifteen thousand
pounds for a couple of hours work is not
bad so below market value and then just
sit on it hold it rent it out for maybe
five six seven hundred pound a month
safe easy gonna go up over time I'm
going three single let by select
properties that's my total nine it's a
recap and it one three service
departments three Hank M owes three by
two that seeing all that's of course I'm
always going to be open-minded and on
the lookout for anything else exciting
that comes up nine it's kind of gonna be
a minimum for me
of course my business is going to be
buying properties as well and I'll be on
the lookout for what comes I think as a
successful property investor really
you're a problem solver and you have
different strategies up your sleeve
lease option agreements rent two ramps
development all these different ideas up
your sleeve and then you just find
people and you
you see if you can help them and you
pull out the cards at the appropriate
time I'm going to be documenting my
journey I'm sure I'm going to end up
finding other properties as well as
those nine if you haven't got any money
and you're looking to do this you can
still do service departments with no
money because you can just read it a
property off the landlord and then do it
a service to put a change into a service
department and keep the cash flow now
you're not benefitting from any capital
appreciation but you are benefitting
from instant cash flow and you've not
put any money down you want to be extra
greedy you can agree to buy it at a
fixed price down the line another option
to buy it so there's many things that
you can do even if you haven't got any
money you can find good property deals
and then you can package them and pass
them on to an investor and charge a fee
and then put that fee in a separate bank
account and keep doing that until you've
got enough to buy a property of your own
there's many things you can do if you've
been inspired by that and if you want to
do property yourself and you're not sure
where to start what I'd like to do is
invite you along to come to our property
investors crash course which is two days
it's absolutely free I'll be there and
I'll be working with you to help put
together your property investment
strategy so that you can get yourself on
the ladder and ultimately enjoy
financial freedom one day so so once
again thanks so much for watching the
video my name is Samuel Leeds and I look
forward to seeing you smash your success
I'm cheering you on in your journey see
you next time
[Music]
you